paul ronzheimer unser bild reporter in
der ukraine heute früh hat er uns
berichtet von immer noch härteren
kämpfen im osten des landes von dem
stetigen vorrücken der russischen armee
keine guten nachrichten hat paul gesagt
heute früh das sind bilder von der im
schaltgespräch in aller frühe um 7 uhr
und dann danach nach diesem gespräch hat
er sich aufgemacht ganz in den osten der
ukraine nach lisi zank und paul hat
heute früh meiner kollegin patricia
platin noch gesagt das ist eine
besonders gefährliche reise weil dort
überall russische truppen sind ein
kessel wird das wenn wir noch mal rein
tja die reise dorthin du hast es
angesprochen ist schwierig ist
kompliziert und ist wahnsinnig
gefährlich denn es gibt nur noch wenige
straßen die dorthin führen patricia man
muss sich das so vorstellen
die russen haben vor diesen bereich
komplett einzukesseln also komplett
einzuschließen um dann die ukrainische
armee dort stellen zu können zur aufgabe
zu zwingen oder dort alle zu töten
eine besonders gefährliche reise hat
paul ronzheimer heute früh gesagt und
das ist besonders gefährlich geworden in
den stunden danach ein angriff auf ihn
auf sein team paul in diesem auto
paul unter beschuss geraten dort mit
seinem team im ausschuss wurde in diese
richtung
die straße ist wahrscheinlich die
gefährlichste
ukraine gerade gibt
gefährlichste straße sagt paul wir
schauen noch mal rein in diese bilder
wir haben gerade auch vielleicht haben
sie es schon sehen und hören jetzt nach
asien beschuss die löcher entscheiden
hinter mir das fenster autos gesehen was
von den
erwischt worden ist
die russen schießen hier diesen weg war
das der einzige weg raus ist aus der
stadt
dieses kreist sagt paul nach diesen
szenen es raus aus dieser umkämpften
stadt und ist jetzt bei uns
immer schön dass du lebst
decke kaya es war tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich einer der gefährlichsten
situationen die wir unser team erlebt
haben hier in den vergangenen monaten
war die jorgos und ich wir haben drei
stunden dort in lizenz verbracht das ist
diese stadt nur noch wenige menschen
leben monate lang keinen strom kein
wasser dort mit zivilisten gesprochen um
zu erfahren um zu berichten für bild was
dort passiert und dann wir waren auf dem
weg raus und dachte jetzt ist eigentlich
alles gut jetzt vom gefühl her wir haben
es geschafft so zu sagen aber dann
wieder dieser gefährliche weg und man
sieht ja auf dem einen video wir hinten
auch diese scheibe explodiert wir haben
vor uns mindestens vier explosionen
gesehen direkt auf der straße das ist
diese straße wo zivilisten raus können
wo aber natürlich auch das ukrainische
militär unterwegs ist und deswegen auch
unter beschuss steht aber für mich ganz
klar die russen machen eben kein
unterschied zwischen zivilen zielen und
militärischen zielen das konnte man da
ganz klar sehen es war sehr
wahrscheinlich mörserbeschuss und sie
sind ganz ganz nah an dieser letzten
straße ja das ist also meter von mir
entfernt gewesen ich weiß paul du magst
es gar nicht wenn man über dich über
dein eigenes reporter leben dort so sehr
spricht in diesem fall müssen wir das
allerdings einmal tun du hast im auto
auch mit jorgos und war dort unterwegs
mit den kameraleuten mit denen die sich
auch vor ort auskennen dort in der
ukraine du hast dann im auto noch teile
dieses geschosses gefunden richtig
ja es gab diesen beschuss dort und wir
haben versucht das zu untersuchen was es
gewesen sein könnte also ist es für uns
nicht ganz klar als wie gesagt diese
explosion deuten für uns auch
mörserbeschuss hin
aber ja es ist eine situation die jeder
zeit passieren kann aber wir haben uns
danach schon alle in den arm genommen
und
uns gefreut dass wir noch am leben wir
nehmen dich von hier in den armen paul
denn der schock sitzt auch uns in den
gliedern als du das video geschickt dass
wir haben heute früh noch kommuniziert
und du hast gesagt dass du in diese
region fährst dass das eine gefährliche
reise wird weil es dort eben weil dort
so ein kessel entsteht weil es dort
offenbar nur diesen einen weg geben
rausgibt aus der stadt und dann hast du
uns am nachmittag geben dieses video
geschickt was sagt dir dass jetzt über
den verlauf dieses krieges dort im osten
der ukraine
es ist für mich sehr klar dass die
russische armee auch diese stadt
irgendwann komplett unter kontrolle hat
also man sieht dass die reichweite eben
für moerser gegeben ist auch auf dieser
letzten straße die menschen die wir dort
getroffen haben waren teilweise schwer
depressiv haben uns in den kellern
gezeigt wie sie bislang leben viele
wollen trotzdem nicht weg dort weil sie
sagen sie haben nicht sie haben kein
geld sie wissen nicht wohin also sie
warten dort sozusagen auf die russen ich
kann nicht sagen wie hoch der
prozentsatz ist aber einige von ihnen
hoffen auch darauf dass die russen
kommen dort in dieser speziellen stadt
und aber es ist wirklich
ja man es fehlen einem wirklich die
worte wenn man dort dank geht und diesen
dauerbeschuss hört und sieht und sieht
was die russische armee
gnadenlos kaputt macht dort ja und wir
zeigen ihnen diese bilder und dieser
reportage von paul auch weil unser
eindruck seit vielen wochen ist das so
eine gewöhnung stattgefunden hat dann
das was an schrecklichem kriegsleid dort
in der ukraine passiert paul
absolut das war auch mein eindruck als
ich zwei drei wochen zurück in
deutschland war eine pause gemacht hat
nachdem wir so lange berichtet haben
eben aus kiel aus dem don budge über
drei monate und in deutschland hatte ich
das gefühl hatte man sich so an diesen
krieg gewöhnt dass man kaum noch
hinschaut
diese bilder natürlich
in lizenz müssen uns aber zeigen dass
dieser krieg auf brutalste und noch
brutaler ist als je zuvor war danke dir
paul ronzheimer noch mehr als an anderen
tagen und ich hoffe dass sie ein
bisschen schlaf findet heute danke